[Music]
oculus is a new horror film about a
mirror a very evil mirror that doesn't
like people or plants for that matter
the only really major star in this film
is Katee Sackhoff and you may remember
her from shows like Battlestar Galactica
she was recently in Riddick
she's a pretty cool actually a chance to
talk to her one time on the schmoes know
podcast that was awesome but besides her
there really aren't that many well-known
stars in the film and that's kind of
cool because you can actually experience
this film without having any
preconceived thoughts about these actors
for the most part least I didn't what
this film is about is a family that has
been extremely adversely affected by
this supernatural presence of some kind
that's within this mirror you're not
sure what it is you're not sure if it's
entirely real even there's a sense of
doubt as the film continues we are
wondering if this brother and sister who
are attempting to prove this mirror is a
supernatural force you're wondering is
this actually true maybe they're just
crazy
this film splits between 11 years in the
past and the present we get to see them
as kids experiencing the horrible family
situation that developed when they
acquired this rare vintage mirror and
then we see them as adults and these
stories converge back and forth and it's
actually extremely interesting and I
really like this movie a lot I'm really
excited to tell you guys this movie was
actually pretty awesome it was very well
directed and that is one of the best
best things I can say about a horror
film this film looks so great it's
filmed very well and the tension and it
feels real to me it's very beautifully
edited and although the first act can be
a little slow I was interested because
of how well directed it was and because
the actors seemed like they actually
cared you know it wasn't just some
stupid horror film with these throwaway
characters and birds jumping out of
cupboards cats that run by really fast
and scare you
none of that annoying stupid crap is in
this movie there's a couple jump scares
but for the most part the tension and
the suspense in this film comes from a
very disturbing family situation and
that is one of the things about this
movie that worked so well for me because
another film recently that came out was
sinister and in that film I thought the
horror
aspects of it were really cool every
single time ethan hawke popped on one of
those tapes I was like this is gonna be
cool let's see what they do but then
whatever you was arguing with his wife
and things weren't going well with his
children I wasn't as invested in the
film oculus has very interesting family
tension and a real domestic situation
that I found myself invested in as well
as the scary horror bump and the night
stuff and that's one of the reason this
movie worked so well for me because I
cared about both aspects of that it was
really clever the way they melded the
past with the present you have to see
the adult children working together to
try to figure out a way to prove that
this supernatural existence of this
mirror and whatever's going on with it
is actually true they got cameras all
over the place and it's not stupid found
footage like oh they're gonna capture
stuff with these cameras and it's gonna
be all shaky and disturbing it's nothing
like that it's filmed and edited very
well so you got that central story that
takes place in the present but you
constantly cut back to when these two
kids were younger experiencing the first
effects of this mirror and you get to
learn why certain things happen to their
family and how they ended up the way
they are in the present they connect
these two stories so seamlessly and I
found it very very intense and I really
enjoyed oculus as I said my only issue
with the film is that the first act does
feel like okay we're getting to that
point where it starts but the fact is
the musical score is so cool very
electronic very simple but effective
Katee Sackhoff was very good in this
movie I think this might actually be the
best performance I've seen from her I
thought she did an excellent job in this
movie and because of the good
performances from the two young stars
their brother and his sister and even
when they were kids especially the
younger girl when she was a kid she was
excellent very good child performance
because of those good performances and
because of the stylistic direction I was
able to overlook some of the more slow
aspects of the way the films started but
around like the half hour market was
like boom unrelenting awesome suspense
for the rest of the film I really
enjoyed oculus it really surprised me
I'm very happy to say that I'm gonna
give oculus an a-minus if you're not a
horror fan you're not gonna like it as
much as I did I tend to really dislike
quite a bit of horror films because the
majority of them nowadays are made so
shoddily but this one was made with
skill and acted well and that's why I
really enjoyed it
I want to give a shout out to this
really awesome gentleman that I met at
the screening he was a fan of mine we
talked for a while he was really cool
and I hope that your dreams about
starting a YouTube channel work out for
you sir guys let me know what you
thought of oculus if you have seen it or
if you were excited to see it I'm
curious to know what your thoughts are
and as always thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck with nice
[Music]